yeah you know live chair
thank you tom right good morning
members of the committee ladies and
gentlemen of the public
and other members who happen to be
watching in
welcome to this special community and
resources committee
it's the one that'll set the budget for
next year
first of all apologies for absence
thank you chair one apology i've
received from
councillor hatchins councillor clark
will be substituting
thank you uh item two public
contributions
nobody looking to make any comment
so we can go past that one
declarations of interest for the benefit
of members of the public if any member
of the committee has a financial or
family interest in any item which is
being discussed
they have to declare it and keep away
from the meeting
with general matters of budget
members of course are council taxpayers
but they are entitled to
comment and vote because of course
if you didn't allow that nobody would be
able to vote
all members do know the routine very
well
item four agreement of the agenda
between parts one
and two uh it suggested from the chair
that
item 11 environmental center should be a
part two item and i propose that
is there a second day i'll second it
coaster james thank you
we have to take a formal vote on this
one
thank you thank you chair councillor
brenton
or councillor bright
paul councillor bushby boar
councillor christie oh
uh counselor dart i don't know if she
has joined us
yes sorry i have um and yeah four
thank you councillor dart councillor
hicks
poor counselor james
four councillor laws
for counselor lock
or pencil mcgoff i'm against
councillor wiseman or
councillor clark
that's 11 4 chair and one against
thank you all right
item five urgent matters i've got
nothing but whether steve has i don't
know
actually i've got nothing right
so item six
the environmental center there's um
a brief verbal update to come from
someone steve i guess
uh sean's going to do that um and then
reid proposed moving into part two to do
the the main item
okay thank you um it's only a very quick
headline um introduction to the item
really
so for any members of the public who are
listening they'll know why we want to
break into part two and what's about to
be discussed so it's long been stated
strategic priority in the council that
we should deliver a new environment
center
um we desperately need to locate all of
our operational services on one side for
reasons of efficiency and health and
safety
we also have now sort of been
researching
and we've reached a point where we need
some decisions
and a clear steer from members on things
like
budget location and scope of project
and so we propose to move into part two
for those detailed discussions
because we don't want to compromise the
commercial position of either the
council or the people selling the land
thank you thank you i don't
propose to move into part two at this
stage i'll deal with the rest of the
agenda
and then we'll deal with part two at the
end so that the public aren't left
hanging around
are we happy with that yes
proper job right we now move on to
item seven miscellaneous fees and
charges
pages three to thirty three
um finance the 1501 officer will deal
with this one
chair before we do yeah declare an
interest
um i have an interest in the caravan
park part of it we
might be discussing campervan fees so i
better step aside for this one
fair enough
okay okay thank you chair and for
members
president this is actually an annual
report that we do on our fees and
charges
um generally the fees and charges can be
split into two main categories some
which are statutory by nature which are
indicated and some which are
discretionary at the discretion of the
council
obviously certain charges such as
planning fees are stature in their laid
down by government we don't have any
control over those charges um inflation
has been relatively low so
generally with the exception of garden
waste and parking
charges which will be considered later
in the main budget report
we've increased them by inflation but
where this has made a
minimal increase some of the charges
have been left unabated
um the crematoria charges they're due to
a separate report there's a north devon
board for the crematory services we
share with our colleagues at north devon
council they meet on the 5th of february
so they'll report back on that i don't
intend to go through
line by line each charge within the
report
and it's just over to you however to
approve the report
or not
[Music]
right ken do you wish to say anything as
leader
right no i'm a happy chairman it's a
first class report
we've gone through it a couple of times
and i'm happy
for us to agree to the charges of the
services effective from
april the first so i take it we we move
that
as a recommendation you're proposing the
recommendation
thank you uh we'll have a second day
later on
now who wishes speak
all right well someone second it and we
can move on
i do have my hand up chair on my side
rose sorry cancer lock just to say um
you're clicking the wrong
raise hand button when you click
reactions it's at the bottom with the
words raised hand next to it
i think you're using a wave sign which
the chair might not be able to see
oh yeah i've got oh wait oh i've got a
thumbs up
is it further down oh yeah right yeah
right got it
sorry yes that better yeah
just one point on page 23 of the report
where it's got the list of car parks
should not barley grove and sydney house
car parks be under torrents and not
holes were they
there's no you know statutory heading
for torrington on that list they all
seem to come under holes were they
page 23
seems to me you're right rose
uh sure sure here um
well the answer is yes they are in
wholesaling and they should be heading
under a heading impulsively so that's
that's a clerical error it doesn't
affect the figures
right and could you explain that cut off
our listed
well um well part is that the one in new
street torrent
[Music]
and it's the one that's near the leisure
center and it's a pound a day
tariff in that car all right so that's
not the free one in torrington
nope right thank you
councilor laws
thank you chair um sean may be able to
answer this
i'm a little confused westwood home
car park permits we're showing two there
a residence per year and a season per
half year
i was under the impression that we
didn't do any season tickets at all on
the main parking ground
um that it was just daily charges
that might have been in the past perhaps
sean can clarify
because i mean to it just seems a bit
inappropriate with a very fast turnover
parking ground
that we've got annual fees there
thank you chair
so chair i don't have the um
unfortunately uh off street parking
places order in front of me so i can't
uh clarify the entire arrangement center
but i um i think you are right
in terms of resident parking resident
permit parking
council of laws and i do think uh we
accept
tourist permits the weekly tourist
permits in that car park
but i'll need to confirm that outside of
the meeting because i don't have the
order in front of that that that's fine
it's just
that the i've never known the annual
um there you know it's actually in the
parking garage it's got residents per
year 60 pounds
and that just seems perhaps you could
check that and check can we
perhaps hold that little item in advance
if necessary till sean's
checked and i wouldn't want to vote for
it
um it will be against the council's own
interest i think
thank you okay can you look that one up
sean
uh yes not in the meeting i think i can
try chair if i
if i look a little distracted that's me
trying to find this document
whilst i'm in the meeting on the
computer it's page 25 of the report sure
no i
so yeah i can see that cancel the laws
thank you i just need to
um if you like whilst the meeting's
happening i'll be on the same device
looking up in the files the on off
street parking places order
so that i'll see if i can answer your
question thank you
okay okay check check i had something
the actual
parking charges uh will be considered
under the next report
uh that's why in this report they're
shown with red blocks against them
because they're part of the main budget
report
so members can still consider this item
while sean looks looks that up in time
for the next item
okay whilst we're
talking at them i was surprised the
other
night i went for a meal
or a long time ago now unfortunately
down to northam and parked
in the main car parking behind the
church to walk up through the church
yard
in the evening and that car park was
chuck a block and yet as i understand it
that's a free car park
uh yes chad you're referring to bone
hill car
park in northern like i suspect that
one's uh leased to northern tank council
and they
provide it free oh no
okay i've got no one else wishing to
speak on this item um
the recommendation on page five i think
it was
uh was that we consider them
do we agree them subject to counselor
laws
one query
we've got a proposal is there a second
cancellation
thank you your query is still to be
sorted counselor laws that's successful
that's fine thank you are we good yeah i
could answer
i'd share i could answer that now if you
wanted me to yes please
uh so the westwood home main car park
listed in the permitted permits then
are a 60 pound per annum residence
parking valid between 4pm and 10am
each day and all day on sundays
a seasonal permit 189 pounds
a half year currently and
a business permit at 158 pounds for half
a year but those last two
are only available between uh first of
november and the 14th march
so permits have permitted those types of
permits the council laws are talking
about
are committed in the off season
thank you sean
okay we have a proposal under and a
seconder to accept that report
can i put it to the vote please thank
you chair
councillor brenton or councillor bright
or chancellor bushby or
pencil christie oh
counselor dart or ancella hicks
or counselor james or
ansler laws or counselor lock
or pencil mcgoff yes
councillor wiseman
i i was abstaining from this one oh
sorry
counselor clark oh
that's unanimous chair thank you
extension right we now move on i believe
to item eight
uh which is gonna be uh
section one five one officer again
thank you chair uh there's a
presentation in tom's just getting the
presentation ready on your screens
so if you just bear with us
[Music]
okay thank you tom um so what we're
going to cover through this presentation
well i'll briefly touch on the impact of
colvid19 on the council's finances
there'll be a bit of refresher on where
the council gets its funding from
i'll go through the 2021-22 provisional
local government settlement essentially
that's the grants that government um are
going to provide to us
some key themes and assumptions um we'll
go through the capital
i'll highlight some risk of
uncertainties in the budget projections
presented to you
uh go through where we are now and how
we may bridge the gap and obviously end
with some recommendations
uh next slide please tom
well kovid 19 it's been an exceptional
year for all local authorities including
torridge
our fee income from fees and charges is
hit by the nash ferris national lot
downs in particular car parking
in the first lot down in the sort of
april may june period
and we're predicting this year to be
half a million down
conversely other income has been sharply
up planning in particular
uh other income that's gone down for the
council has been our interest
income that we get from our short-term
treasury deposits due to the bank of
england base rate
cut and we're looking at a shortfall in
the country of 125 000 pounds
also the government's tasked the council
of delivering various tranches of
government grants
so we've delivered substantial amounts
of business support grant probably to
date
we probably got probably spent 30
million pounds
um track and taste payments 500 pounds
for people who have got been told to
self-isolate
and those hardship grants of course
we've incurred some additional
expenditure additional ppe cleaning of
our hostels and council facilities
the it investments has allowed us to
facilitate homework in
uh increased support for our leisure
services and the admin burden of
delivering various government grants to
businesses
next slide please tom so just how
unusual
has 2020-21 been well in a normal year
we know and spend about 16 million
pounds if we ignore housing benefit
which we pay on behalf of the department
of work and pensions
i think the comparable figure this year
will be 60 million pounds
so by a factor of three that's how much
extra
expenditure has gone through the
council's coffers this year
next slide please tom
okay so in recognition of the impact
kovid 19 has had on the finances a local
government central ground provided
various tranches of financial support
so we've had just under 1.2 million in
kovid 19 expenditure support grants
we've had new burdens grant which is i
don't you know recognize the additional
responsibilities an extra workload that
the council's had of just under
a third of a million and we're
anticipating getting some compensation
for our loss fees and charges of about a
third of a million
we're still projecting a surplus for
this year
uh which will be amount for the capitals
program which is underfunded at this
moment
and there's a variety of reasons why
we've underspent
to a large degree the additional
responsibilities that central government
have put upon the council we've absorbed
by using existing staff
there has been some over time there's
been some increased house we haven't
generally employed extra staff there's
been the lowest instance of covid in
england within turret so that's when we
haven't
like some council had to do a lot of
backfill for our frontline refuge
service
there was a significant bounce back of
our parking income due to the staycation
factor the people couldn't go abroad on
holiday to these
they're vacated within the uk so i'm
sure
all members know how busy um torres was
during the summer
we've had a completely extraordinary
year for planning
income which is about 400 grand above
target we believe
and that's against a budget just over
half a million so that's the scale of
how much um
planning income we've had in this year
and i think it's fair to say the council
has been very prudent about his use of
his resources to support partners such
as the legends providers we've not just
thrown money at the problem
we've engaged in debate and prudent
analysis of the demands
next slide please tom
um i think with all things covered i
think sometimes it's easy to forget that
we've got the day-to-day job to do
um so we've got to remember the council
still needs to deliver its valued
services to its resident and raise
sufficient revenue to actually fund
these activities so we've still got to
pick up the waste we've still got to
clean the streets we've still got to do
food hygiene inspection
we've still got to collect council tax
look after our parts
undertake elections public conveniences
etc next slide please tom
okay this you've got two little charts
there on the screen
this is you just need to recognize where
the council gets its revenue from
so the pie chart to the left-hand side
shows that fees and charges
which you've just approved some
increases too are
and the biggest component of our income
at 38 followed by council tax
followed by our retained share of
business rates and government grants
are only about 10 of our normal revenue
obviously
2021 was completely different because of
all the kovid related grants
and the chart to the right-hand side of
the lines just shows the long-term
trends and if you can just point out the
line which is the government grants
that's in long-term decline back in
2013-14 we're just under 4 million
pounds and we're
you know we're probably about one and a
half million now so it's in long-term
decline
essentially we stand on our own two feet
by the money that we
raise um members have a direct
debt decision directly impact upon the
revenue the council can generate from
fees and charges and council tax next
slide please tom
okay the provisional local government
set up so on the 17th of december the
central government pronounced the local
government financial settlement
and the headline figure which may be
reported in the daily mail and the bbc
etc would have said
that the core spending power for the
local authority is set to increase by
4.5
for torrids this was zero percent
it's important to know that 85 of the
increase in the core spending power
announced by the government
relates to the council's ability to
increase their council tax
up to their referendum limits so just as
an aid memoir for members what does
government include when it says our core
spending power
well we have the revenue support grant
the rural services delivery grant which
we get entourage because we're a very
rural community and the government
recognizes extra costs of delivering our
services in a very rural area
retained business grant business rate
income and the
section 31 grants for those relief new
homes bonus
a new grant which is a lower services
services grant
social care grants which of course don't
apply to tourists because we're not an
upper tier authority
and council tax income next slide please
tom okay there's a bar chart here
um which shows the blue is the grant
that we're receiving in the current
financial year 2020-21
and the red shows the grant that we will
receive in 2021
22 and ignoring some colvid grant
funding which we'll get for 2020-21 the
mainstream central government grant
funding for turret has declined by 183
000
so as you can see the revenue support
grant it's basically the same
next year as this year there's been a
very modest increase in the rural
services delivery grant
and you can see a very sharp drop-off in
our new homes bonus
funding the lower services tourist
services tear grant which you can see
which is a new grant for 2020-21
that reflects in some ways compensating
us for the drop
in the new homes bonus so make sure that
we our core spending power doesn't
actually go
negative and we've had some increase in
the homelessness funding
but the important point to note is
without an increase up to the council
tax referendum limit
torres will see a significant decline in
its core spending power in 2021-22
next slide please tom
okay as i stated
the local government settlement assumes
that councils and their preceptors will
increase their council tax
up to their referendum limits that's the
assumption of government
so for devon county council that's two
percent plus three percent for a social
care precept
for devon and cornwell police that's 15
pound for a band d
equivalent council tax property which
equates to six point eight percent
for devon or someone set fire two
percent for torridge five pound for a
band d equivalent property which equates
to two point nine six percent
there are no referendum limits for our
town and parish councils
the little by chart below is where i've
assumed a two percent increase for our
town and paris council then it's assumed
that all the preceptors
raised their charge up to their
referendum limits
if that was the case the chart for band
d property would rise by 95 pounds and
six pence of which todd's share
would be five pound and on that chart
that is the yellow item so what i'm
really trying to indicate is
there's going to be a significant
increase in the council charge in terms
of
in figure the figure will be 95 pound
we're a very small proponent of that
we cannot really influence the charge
very much because the main component
is devon county council then it's the
fire in the police and then ourselves
next slide please tom
okay and trying to reset the council tax
is a
vital source of revenue for the council
and its impact is felt
beyond the year the increase is in greed
agreed
and whilst we're the billing of forest
for the council's tax its share of
council tax has been in long-term
decline so if you see the chart below
you there
um every year our percentage of the
council tax bill
even though it's our name on the top of
the bill declined year
after year after year and we'll continue
to do so because the precept
sorry the referendum limits for the
preceptors are generally more generous
than they are for ourselves
next slide please tom
and the little table there it's trying
to indicate that
whilst we quote the increase for account
stats as a band d
equivalent the majority of our residents
the ones in a b and c don't actually pay
up to a band-aid
a so a council tax increase of five
pound per van d
equivalent equates to less than 10 pence
a week for 85 percent of our residents
so 85 percent of our residents if we
were to raise our council tax by five
pound for bandy
it would equate to less than 10 pence
per week
that's all those people in bands a to d
and 67 percent of our residents live in
bands a to c and would actually pay less
than the five pound increase
net slide please tom
as he alluded to earlier there's an
impact it's felt it
over the long term by not increasing
council tax
back in 2010 2011
um 2012-13 the government gave
non-recurrent grant funding
to councils which didn't increase their
council tax
and of course the consequence of that is
when the non-recurrent grant funding
fell away the council had foregone
increases in its council tax and
therefore was in a cumulatively worse
position
if we'd increased our council tax in
line with the referendum limits and not
taken the government's offer the
non-recurrent council tax freeze grant
we'd be collecting about 440 000 pounds
more council tax each year and we would
not have forgotten about three million
pounds worth of income and we've only
come to the capital the gap in the
capital program that gives some context
to it
could i have the next slide please tom
okay so i'm just going to go through
some of the key assumptions in the
budgets
um so first off council tax this time
last year in february i said council tax
is by far the most stable form of income
the council can ever have
because at that time i didn't know we
were going to have a global pandemic
generally our collection rate of council
tax is between 98.5
and 99 with modest changes from year to
year
we're projecting the council tax
collection rate for 2021
two thousand twenty twenty one the
current financial is going to be ninety
six point five
and we're projecting the collection rate
for next year to be ninety seven point
four five we believe this is due to the
impact of culvert
then after we expect the collection rate
to increase by half a percent each year
up to 2024-25
my budget projections assume that the
council tax will be increased in line
with referendum limits
over the life of the median term
financial strategy
business rates this year's been an
exceptional year for business rates
the government has announced various
business rate release to help business
through these difficult times
as a consequence the collectible
business rates in
with intolerance declined from 12
million to four and a half million
we have been compensated by section 31
grants from government
at the time of writing this report at
the time of making this presentation
i have not heard anything from
government about whether they're going
to extend any of these
reliefs into 2021-22
and the budget as presented to assumes
exceptionally modest increases in our
business rates over the life of the
median term financial strategy
next slide please tom
so what are the other key assumptions
well i alluded to
our loss of income on our short-term
treasury deposits from the decline in
the bank of england base rate
i'm not expecting a dramatic increase in
interest rates
i'm expecting interest rates not to get
back to pre-covered 19 levels until
2025-26
the income from fees and charges
excluding the car parking and guideways
which we'll discuss later
i've assumed that our income from fees
and charges will remain as per the
budget for 2020-21
of course i don't know that because i
don't know what the impact of colvid19 i
don't know how successful the rollout of
the vaccine
will be we have covered in terms of
we've got
the government's compensation scheme for
lost fees and charges
it has been extended to june 2021 so we
have some scope there
but i've not made any i've assumed that
our fees and charges
will stay at the budgeted 2021-20 to
2020-21 figures
right the spending review and um
sorry the government's uh local
government um settlement and spending
review announced a freeze on public
sector pay
now technically local authorities aren't
part of the public sector for
um national for public sector pay
however we've had received no extra
funding from the government to fund any
pay awards
and i would expect that um the local
government association would follow
central government's guidance on pay
awards so therefore i've assumed
zero percent pay award for the staff
except for those on less than 24 000
pounds per year where they
expect to increase 250 pounds a one
percent pay award in 2022-23
a 1.5 percent in 2023 24
and a 2 pay award in 2024 25.
of course this is it isn't in the gift
of torres district council
this will be determined nationally next
slide please tom
right it's also i've recognized that
leisure has been particularly badly hit
by covid19
members have been on various meetings
where we've discussed the issues
relating to the provision of our leisure
services
and consequently i've assumed an
additional 150 000 pounds per annum is
included in our median term financial
strategy to reflect the an estimate of
additional costs of providing leisure
facilities
throughout the council's area next slide
please tom
okay so where are we heading for
so obviously we've had some major
assumptions some major hits on our
revenue the first one is the new homes
bonus
which has dramatically gone down uh
we're going to discuss this later in the
presentation but i've included
additional 170 000 pounds a year
towards funding the environmental center
and that we're going to make additional
contributions to our capital programme
to cover um ongoing maintenance in
respect to car pass and general
maintenance amount into 180 000 pounds
i've alluded to the loss of income from
our short-term treasury deposit because
of the bank of england base
rate cost and i've alluded to the
increased cost of anticipating in
respect of leisure
so the little chart that you see in
front of you the blue is the deficit i'm
projecting now
and the red is the deficit that i was
protecting when i last reported to full
council in february 2020 and as you can
see
i'm forecasting an increased deficit
each year
next slide please tom
the council has a transition in
government funding reserve and this
reserve is used to balance the council's
revenue budgets until either expenditure
savings
or additional revenue streams are
identified
and the projected use of this reserve
based on the identified deficits from
the previous slide are shown below
so we have at the moment just under just
over 1.2 million in our transition in
government funding reserve
if we took no corrective action and
based on the projections i'm
doing for the medium-term financial
strategy you will see
that the uh transition in government
funding reserve goes negative in 2023-24
actually quite uh quite early in 2023-24
because we've virtually exhausted it if
you luke
at the end of 2022-23 so what i'm saying
is the
building society account that we have to
help ourselves through these difficult
times would run out quite quickly if
we've made no corrective action
next slide please tom
okay capital
the capita the council's approved
capital program is 23 million
and there's currently a funding gap at
2.2 million
before the council adds new capital
projects and addresses the funding
issues pertaining to the proposed
environment center
it should be noted that only 7.7 million
of the funding required is actually held
in our capital reserves our
capital reserves our capital receipts so
the yellow
bar is the size of the capital program
the next bar is actually that the money
that we've actually got set aside that's
7.7 million
we're forecasting additional
contributions to the capital program
that would either be from capital
receipts
um capital grants or contributions from
our revenue budgets at the moment
primarily contributions on a month
on a yearly basis towards the
replacement of our refuge and
street cleansing fleet we've also got
approved borrowing of five million
and obviously the bar to the right-hand
side is the funding gap
but as i said before we added any new
capital programmes or
really to address the issues relating to
the environmental center
and that's why i please tom
so why do we have a funding gap uh well
there's two main factors
this constructor industry build
inflation that's gone up every
you know honestly projects gets delayed
we've got to incur
um additional inflation by the time we
get round to actually delivering on the
projects
but the big one is the decline in our
new homes bonus funding
if you look back at 2016-17 the council
got
just over two million pounds in new
homes bonus that meant we could put one
million pounds
in that year away to fund our capital
program
if you look to what i'm projecting for
2022-23
it's virtually nil so we
that that source of funding of our
capital program has gone
and we've at this stage we don't know
what's going to replace it so that's a
big issue
and we need to address this next slide
please tom so
how we so the funding gap i alluded to
before adding any new schemes
was 2.2 million then we've identified
that we need a rolling program of
maintenance for our car parts and our
other assets
of 900 000 pounds over the life of the
median term financial strategy 180 000 a
year
just to give some context the value of
the council's land and building property
for as per our audited account
is 38 million we
some of that's land admittedly but we
have a quite
extensive property portfolio and that
needs to be maintained and we need to be
set inside a fund to maintain that
property portfolio we've identified that
we should be setting money aside for a
leisure contingency
for repairs that need to be done and to
bring our electric facilities
up to specification and there's the
increased cost of the environmental
sensor which is discussed in a later
report
and the town hall roof costs at 760 000.
so if we go from a gap a 2.2 million to
a projected
funding gap on our capital program of
5.7 million
uh next slide please tom
so how we going to bridge the funding
gap on the capital programme
so i think it's probably best that we
break it down into three components
so we're the approved capital program
the 2.2 million gap that we started with
plus the leisure contingency in the town
hall roof come to 3.3 million
then they've got the environmental
center the increase 1.5 million
and the role in programmer works i
setting money aside to maintain our
existing portfolio of properties
next slide please tom so just talking
about the 3.3 million
which is the existing 2.2 million and
the add in the leisure contingency
and the town hall roof how can we bridge
that well
there's certain savings we have in the
existing program particularly the
borough center which is about half a
million by paring down that project and
getting additional external granting
we've got some capital receipts which
hopefully will materialize
over the next few years cleave wood tad
worthy bridge buildings
westwood hole part which we've already
received and
against that i put a contingency there
because none of these uh receipts are
guaranteed apart from the west window
part which we've actually received so
continuous for non-receipt
and any future capital schemes which may
come of half a million
as i alluded to we're forecasting a
surplus for the current financial year
at 642 000 and we're anticipating we
shall put
that to the capital programme and we're
going to make a contribution from 2021
to 22s budgets to 275
000 and essentially as you can see there
with a fair wind
we may be able to bridge that gap of 3.3
million pounds next slide please tom
okay i've alluded to that we're going to
have to build
the new environment center is going to
cost us additional funding
and the the actual borrowing we've got
some money set aside
in our capital reserves but essentially
we would have to borrow 5.6 million
which gives us an annual cost of 382 000
to service that amount of debt or
borrowing
there are identified savings relating to
having an environmental center and
there's a later report we'll identify
but that increased income from recycling
primarily
so that still means we'd have to find an
additional 170 000 pounds a year and
that's been built into our median term
financial strategy
if we were to increase our garden waste
charge for five pound each year over the
next three years that would generate
another 180
000 pounds per annum by 2023 24.
if you look to the bottom right of the
screen you will see that at the moment
we are the cheapest amongst our
neighbouring authorities
um mid devon are already at 50 pound
east devon at 48
cornwall at 43 west devon at 40.
um next slide please tom
so how would we bridge the gap on the
rolling program this is the money that
we as i alluded to earlier we need to
set aside for our existing portfolio of
properties
um so it's 180 000 pounds a year we
believe we need to set aside
and we've there's a little table there
which identifies how we may do this by
increasing our parking charges they're
contained in the report and if we do it
as a staggered event over three years we
can raise additional income
to meet that additional contribution and
so by the year free
we're actually raising more income than
the additional contributions we're
forecasting to put aside
for um to fund our ongoing rolling
programme
i think it was recognized that this
possibly is a better way of doing it
than actually cutting some of our
services which will affect the most
vulnerable in our communities
next slide please tom
okay i just want to allude to some risk
and uncertainties before we move on
essentially we've been signposted
there's gonna be changes to the local
government financing for many years
and that was first delayed because of
brexit and of course now it's been
delayed because of covid 19.
and the components of local government
funding which are going to be revisited
are the controversy spending review and
that's basically how big will the local
authority sector
kate be how much will be assigned to
local authorities
the fair funding review says what slice
of the cape will today's receive
they're going to review business rate
retention currently torres district
council retains
40 of all business rates that it
collects
and there's going to be a replacement
scheme for new homes bonus now there's a
little chart there
on the left hand side in red is shy
districts and on the right hand side
my i'm a bit colorblind but i'm going to
guess that is green is shire counties
which is a very low figure
essentially under local business rate
retention shy districts such as
ourselves have done remarkably well
in terms of our growth from it and
benefited from it and that's because
we've got low
need we don't we don't look after social
services we don't look after education
but we retain a large share of the
business rates
if the the review of local business rate
retention scheme is going to come into
effect
it is likely that there will be from
some transfer of resources from shy
districts to shy counters so clearly be
unrealistic to expect us to be
a favorable recipient of any changes to
local government
local business rate retention next slide
please tom
okay the overall risk of uncertainty
what are the longer term
impacts of the kovid 19 there could be a
recession or likely recession
that was going to increase the claims
for local council tax support
because so little business rates have
actually been collected and released
been awarded
we don't actually know how much empty
business rates there are out there
we don't get compensated for empty
business rate relief that's awarded
there's some people probably haven't
claimed empty business rate relief
because they haven't had a business
rates bill to pay
we may i don't we may get issues of
collecting the council tax going forward
there's people being hit by some of the
adverse impact of the kovid 19.
i said that the fees and charges budget
i've assumed as per
the budget for 2020-21 however
who knows what the long-term impact they
may be because of it we may have more
people working from home over the long
term and that may mean there's less
footfall in our town centres
so less car parking income quite clearly
the government has spent a lot of money
meeting the impact of kofi 19 at some
time in time
that debt has to be repaid and it'd be
prudent to expect there may be
reductions in central government funding
going forward
and what are the long-term interest
rates i've assumed that interest rates
will bounce back by 2025-26
if i did know that i'd be working in the
city rather than working for torres
district council
i don't know what the long-term interest
rates are i can only make an assumption
next slide please tom
so what would be the impact if we
increase the fees and charges as
outlined
in the capital report if you can see
there
now on the top slide the blue is the
deficit so as
you can see it's actually less than the
deficit i was reporting
in february 2020 and actually the
revenue budgets come back
into balance by 2024-25
and you also notice what would the
impacts on the utilization of the
of the transition government funding
reserve well it actually means that we
maintain that
we don't exhaust it in 2023 24 and it
means actually by 25 26 we still have
a transition in government funding good
and i've just alluded to previous couple
of slides to the uncertainties
it would be prudent to have that reserve
to meet some of those uncertainties
um next slide please tom
so what are the recommendations that the
community and resources approved the
charges
changes to parking and green waste
charges the garden waste charges
currently 35 pound for an adam is
increased by five pound per annum
by 2021 22 2023 20
2022 23 and 2023 24 at which point the
charge will be 50 pound per annum as
detailed in appendix one
of the capital reports section 3.7.3
increase the car parking charges within
westwood owen appledore as detailed in
appendix 1 capital
report section 3.74 the increase being
phased over three years
increased car parking charges were now
towns of biddeford holdsworth and
torrenson has detailed independence one
capital report section 3.7.4
again phased over three years an
increase other charges such as car
parking permits as detailed in appendix
one
of the capital 3.74 and the rationale
for this is it recognized that the
target increases to garden waste
collection
and car parking are the most extra
equitable way of meeting the funding
pressures pertaining to both the capital
programme and the revenue budgets
next slide please tom
and then there's some other
recommendation that the members of cnr
recommend to full council
there are torrid bandi council tax for
2021 22 be increased by five pound
which is 2.96 percent from 168 pounds 66
to 173 pounds 66. this recognizes
recognizing the council tax is the most
stable
force of funding still centralis
government has assessed our core
spending power on the assumption that we
raise our council tax up to our
referendum limit
our responsibilities to provide
long-term options on managing the
council's finances
and also that our external auditors will
assess the council
in terms of is it a go into concern and
has it demonstrated that it's
financially sustainable
members note recommend to full council
the net revenue budget for 2021.22 is
6.956 million this is just a specific
requirement that we need by statute
that the contributions to reserve
details in 12.4 of the report are
approved again
that's a specific requirement and that
the new
projects identified in the appendix one
of the capital report are approved and
added to the council's approved capital
programme
this recognises that the council has
both ongoing capital maintenance
obligations and pacific capital
expenditure commitments
next slide please tom you'll be glad to
know that's the end of my voice and i'll
hand over now for some comments from the
deputy leader of the council
council claire hudson lead member for
customer services and internal resources
thank you david um that's a been an
excellent presentation as ever
this council has had numerous
opportunities
in the last weeks indeed months
to examine the way forward for this
council
and to achieve a balanced budget
we've had some hard decisions to make
but i think we spent the time
examining all the options open to us
and that we've determined that we need
to maintain
service provision but to raise the
additional funding through fees
and an increase to our council tax
i am not a member of this committee so i
cannot move
these recommendations but i can endorse
the recommendations that are contained
in this report
and i heartily support
all those items that have been noted
i would therefore like to pass over to
my leader
who does have the ability to move those
recommendations
thank you thank you claire um
i'm just enforcing and reinforcing what
you've said we have had a uh
several sessions going all through this
it is an excellent report i must
congratulate david and peter
on the work they've done it's tremendous
and i feel that this is the way forward
and therefore i will
recommend that we adopt the
recommendations that
they go to full council so um
i'll hand back to the chair now channel
for questions and a second
thank you paul thank you ken i take that
as a formal
proposal i will second it from the chair
and now i throw it open to general
discussion of
members of the committee first of all
councillor bright
thank you chad uh yeah i just got one
queries at the
uh meeting we had a couple of weeks ago
where we discussed
these some of these charges and
different ideas of funding
um i did ask whether we were going to
change
the parking charges in torrington
biddyford
and holdsworthy and it was said nope
that's not part of it it was purely
about the ecuador and northern ones
but here it says we're increasing it by
10k per hour can we explain what's going
on
who's going to take it um if you refer
them to the member event councilor
bright
yep yeah i've i've got here the one of
the
polls um and it actually was 68 percent
in favor of increasing the charges for
biddeford
tollington and holsworthy
council of laws yes uh
yes chair uh a bitter pill not a place
any of us wanted to be um
but we have to support this as a cancer
i mean
our officers have done everything looked
at every opportunity
and going by the pole which i thought
was an excellent
idea it gave a good steer um yeah
i said i i support
right i've got no one else wishing to
speak on this matter
so i'm oh councillor christie yeah thank
you a couple of questions
um in the capital income there were
about the sale of assets
um the two areas which didn't appear
um if we go ahead with the west uh with
the environment center
uh presumably we will be selling wescom
and also a brunswick wharf isn't there
and the planning application
is now in so i assume there is a capital
receipt from that
and also have we actually built in to
our car parking
income um going back to brunswick wharf
actually the loss of parents wolf car
parking there from it's down from 116
public spaces down to 45 has that been
built into it so
two questions there what's happened to
the two possible capital receipts and
secondly
have we built and planning sorry the
parking figures
um i'll pick this one up this time if
you like um so the
the disposal of the what would be the
redundant
uh waste recycling sites that was
already built in and factored into the
capital program
in 2017 when the initial decision
uh was taken to move forward with the
consolidation of our sites
now the the brunswick wharf site hasn't
been built in yet
but that would be should it be
should it be received and should that
development progress
as is currently approved by full council
in terms of the car parking on brunswick
wharf obviously that would be a longer
term change
and i guess we would anticipate that
some of that would be relocated to
other car parking sites in and around
biddeford
sean will be able to confirm i believe
there's probably capacity
in some of the other uh local car parks
should uh the need arise and those
uh individuals be relocated
yeah i can confirm that excuse me
there is capacity um and one of the
other things we'll discuss with
um the developer for uh brunswick wolf
should that scheme go ahead
is the provision of some sort of
residence schemes because i think
there's probably mostly resident parking
over there
that has value if i'm honest
okay councillor yeah just a quick
question for david about business rates
am i writing um thinking that uh we
retain 100
of business rates in respect to wind and
solar farms
yes that is correct i know there are two
big applications coming in for
um solar parks in the area so that
might be a bit useful and also i would
go
take one radical step further because
i'm a great believer that if you use a
service you should pay for it
and to absolutely maximize our income
from year one
i would like to see the garden waste for
up to 50 pounds per year straight away
with a caveat saying this to be
maintained for three years
i don't know what other counselors think
about that
counselor dart
thank you i've got to be honest i've
just respond to rose
uh councillor lock in my opinion you
know the list
of um other councils and their charges
for
the garden waste you know we are a
really poor area
let's not forget that and let's not lose
sight of that i
think to do it um periodically over the
three years
five pound every year is reasonable
i don't think it's reasonable to
increase it straight off um to 50 pounds
given our location where we are and our
residents
and also i just i absolutely appreciate
this report
and i think the officers have done a
brilliant job
but frankly there is no way at this
current moment in time
that i will vote for our residents to
pay more in
council tax to torridge
councillor leather
thank you chair well yeah i it was a
very clear
report from david as always um when we
did the
the meeting the other week on the
project initiation documents that was a
good meeting and i think
the steer given from that has come
through this meeting today
when you go back to the start of david's
presentation and you see the amount of
money
that the county council are going to be
able to raise two percent plus three
percent
then you know what the police are
getting a huge increase for the police
we how we are tiny what we actually have
for torridge is
it's very small and that's always grated
with me
because we as david said torres district
council's on the top of the bill and a
lot of people seem to think
we're collecting a huge amount of money
for ourselves when
it's a very small proportion in in
actual fact
as far as the waste um green waste and i
have two bins here
just been empty today i think to put it
up to 50 pounds as
councillor locks it straight away that's
a big jump
you know when you think of the other
increases coming through from
county council the fire and rescue and
the police
on top of our small increase
so i think to phase it in over three
years is the correct way to go
and we none of us like to increase
things but we've got to do it i mean we
with things we need to do and want to do
and this is a very sensible way of doing
it
uh i think as um our deputy leader said
it's been very carefully considered over
quite a few weeks and months this has
and i think the outcome has been a very
fair
result actually thanks chair
councillor james i guess to wind up this
item well
yes uh chair thank you i i would just
like to say
we did look at the um there comes the uh
the waste
uh the green bin collections as to
whether we should put it up quick or
something
but i think what we agreed was that that
was a
measured step to do it over three years
um i
actually did raise whether we should do
it quicker at the time but looked at it
again looked at all the figures
looked at the arguments and decided over
three words years was the correct way to
go
in terms of the council tax i think
we've only got to look back
at the previous chance to see that if
you don't put the council tax up to keep
up with inflation
and to be able to deliver the services
we find that our
funding gap just gets smaller as the
time goes on because you're talking
about
a percentage increase on a percentage
every time and i think
much as i would love to be able to say
we pay less tax
and as a rural area we do pay um
probably disproportionately high council
tax compared to some urban areas
but that's where we are with it so i
fully support what's been done
we have put a lot of time to it as i
said previously
uh a huge thanks to david and to peter
for the work they've done
and i thoroughly recommend that we go
forward with it to full council as it is
thank you chair thank you ken i've got
no one
else wishing to speak i've got a
proposal and a second
to the recommendations in total as set
out on page 55
so i'm going to put them to a vote in
one go
thank you chair councillor brenton you
hear me
hello i can now counselor brenton
okay against councillor bright
against councillor bushby
or councillor christie
or councillor dart
against councillor hicks
for counselor james
for penciller laws or
counselling or counsellor mcgoff
abstain counselor wiseman
councillor clark
that's eight four three against and one
abstention chair
so that is moved and seconded
and approved so we can now move
on um
oh we come to basically the point of
exclusion of public
don't we my apologies to members of the
public that we have to say
cheerio to you but we're going on to
discuss the environmental center
and there's a lot of financial figures
that cannot become public at this stage
so i thank you for your attendance and
your interest in the matter
can we take a vote to it please
thank you chair
for councillor hicks
for councillor james or
cancer laws
counsellor laws
come home
he's turned his camera off sandra so you
might not be there
okay thank you tom
uh councillor lock
councillor mcgoff against
councillor wiseman or councillor clark
or
that's 10 4 one against
and no vote from councillor laws
obviously
sorry i was muted yes four
thank you councillor lords okay sorry
about that
okay thank you to members of the public
cheerio
see you at the next meeting next